NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank...
Where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
I am a former C.I.A. officer,
and if I had to
tell you any more,
I'd have to kill you.
Tell him more!
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for...
Oh, damn.
Whoa. [groans]
...or they'll walk away
with nothing.
My mom had me
at 16 years old.
I'm a first-generation
college student.
Have a heart, Barbara.
Come on.
I have the right to be here.
I've worked so hard.
CUBAN, JOHN, AND HERJAVEC:
Barbara! Barbara!
Come on, Barbara!
NARRATOR: If the sharks hear
a great idea...
I couldn't do anything
on my own.
My wife had to dress me
in the morning.
I'm former WWE world champion
diamond Dallas Page,
and today,
we just broke $3 million.
Dang.
NARRATOR:
They're ready to invest
using their own money...
I'll make you
a $100,000 offer
for 40%.
You thief!
NARRATOR: ...And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I want a dollar a unit.
That doesn't make
any sense.
If you want to make
an offer, Robert,
go ahead and make one.
You are so lucky you've met me.
You have no idea.
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Daymond John is
a fashion and branding expert
who grew
his homemade clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand fubu,
with over $6 billion
in retail sales to date.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
My name is Ryan Carpenter.
I live in Portland, Oregon,
with my turtle, Mo,
and I'm the owner of Moberi.
I love living in Portland.
Portland is the place
where weird ideas thrive,
and what I do is definitely
a little weird,
and people
really like that here.
Leading a healthy lifestyle
is something I've done
for a long time.
I frequently ride my bike around
to the farmers market,
picking up fresh produce.
Can't wait to juice these.
They're gonna go great
in the smoothies.
Yeah, totally.
Yeah.
My goal was to start a business
with $500.
Then, I found a new way
to use old bikes,
and I found a way to mix
my healthy and active lifestyle
and share it with the world.
Standing out in Portland
is not an easy thing to do,
but I've created a product
that turns heads
and gets people excited.
I've put all my savings and
then some into this business,
but for me,
it's not just about the money.
It's about the chance
to do something
that I really like doing
for a living.
My dream for this business
goes so much farther
than my resources can take it.
With an investment
from the sharks,
I can take it to the next level
and make Mo proud.
Hey, sharks.
My name is Ryan Carpenter,
my business is Moberi,
and I'm looking for $50,000
in exchange
for a 15% stake in my company.
Welcome to Moberi,
the first bicycle-powered
smoothie-and-juice cart,
from Portland, Oregon.
Food trucks, bicycles,
and healthy juice bars
are major trends
sweeping the nation right now,
and we combine all three
into an interactive experience
unlike any other.
Using fresh greens,
fruits, and superfoods,
customers come to us to
pedal-power their own smoothies,
or we do it for them.
[laughter]
Either way, the experience
is always fun,
And the product is delicious.
And with a little bit
of your guys' help,
we can take this pedal-powered
concept to a whole new level.
But before
we get down to business,
who wants to come up
and pedal their own smoothie?
Me!
Daymond? All right.
Come on up.
[chuckles]
I want a piece of this.
Mark.
All right.
Daymond,
why don't you hop on that one?
See if that works for you.
Oh, that's funny.
HERJAVEC: Oh, wow.
My, oh, my.
JOHN: Oh, my goodness.
This is pretty funny.
Go, Daymond! Go, Daymond!
CARPENTER: Hold on.
All right, guys.
The trick is to start slow
and then pick up the speed
as we get going.
[laughs]
Nice. I like this.
It's pretty smooth, right?
Yeah.
Five, four, three, two, one!
HERJAVEC: Mark, go faster!
That's it.
Power, not speed.
Nice job, guys.
That's cool.
Sweet.
Did it work?
All right.
There you go.
[laughs]
That's all yours.
There you go.
It's good.
[laughs]
That is really good.
Is it good? Nice.
JOHN: Wow.
That is good.
This is good.
All right. Robert?
Take one of each, here.
The green one here
is the Johnny Utah.
That's got kale,
pineapple, and mint.
HERJAVEC: Wow.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
This thing's amazing.
Wow. The green is great.
Yummy.
All right.
Okay, Ryan.
Quick question.
Sure.
Are you nuts?
[laughs] Uh...
O'LEARY: Think about
the capacity constraint.
Get five guys walking up there
to buy their smoothie,
and they all
have to ride a bicycle?
So, we have one bicycle
inside our current cart,
and we have one bike outside
on our food-cart patio.
CORCORAN: And how would
you even come up
with this
really ridiculous idea?
Ridiculously great idea?
I saw
how a Guatemalan nonprofit
was turning bicycles
into washing machines
and concrete mixers,
and I thought
smoothies would go over
a little bit better
in the Portland market.
What are sales, say?
What have you got for numbers?
So, so far this year,
we've sold $70,000.
We'll be at $100,000
by the end of the year.
Do you have
a single location?
I have
one full-time location,
and I have a mobile cart
that I use for catering.
So, tell me
about the one location.
It's an 8x16 trailer.
I'd say
about 80% of my customers
let us do the pedaling.
What do you charge
for a smoothie?
So, the average
is 6 bucks.
And why do you think
this is gonna become popular,
with all the other
competitions you have --
the jamba juices
and everybody in the world?
Because it's -- it's different.
It's interactive. It's fun.
But, Ryan, after I do it once,
do I care?
Yeah. You do.
Nobody comes into our spot
in a bad mood
and leaves in a bad mood.
They love it.
They come back --
What's it cost for the bike?
So, these particular bikes
ran me about $2,000.
Each?
Each.
That thing cannot cost $2,000,
even with the blender.
These are
my high-end bikes.
My originals, I made
out of Schwinn exercise bikes.
It cost me about 400 bucks
to make one of those bikes.
There was a few problems
with that.
I couldn't lower the seat
all the way down for kids.
These bikes are safer,
more predictable,
and they're gonna give me
long-term return.
But the prem--
the premise is nuts,
because it's a
capacity-constraint function.
I mean, do you have
a real blender back there?
No.
W-what are you, nuts?!
That's part of
the beauty of it.
You don't need a real blender.
No, no, it's not beautiful.
It's ugly!
You really don't.
It's -- it's not.
It's beautiful,
and -- and it's efficient.
I can bust out
as many smoothies on these
in the same timeframe
as a busy Jamba Juice.
Versus a blender?
Now, what do you -- what do you
plan on doing with the money?
With $50,000,
that'll give me enough money
to open two more carts
just like that.
Never mind that, Ryan.
What are you planning
to do with your life?
Downtown --
[laughter]
It's like --
I'm just trying
to stay in shape
and get a smoothie afterward.
[laughter]
Brian,
this is so crazy
that it might actually
be brilliant.
It is.
Brian, I think
it's a very happy business,
and that,
I have to hand to you,
but I have to tell you,
it doesn't make any sense.
Do you guys want to talk
about the numbers?
I'm profitable.
No, you gave us
the numbers.
It's just not investable.
And this is our first year.
I know. I'm out.
Daymond,
you love healthy foods.
You love --
you love to be outside.
JOHN: Brian,
you look like a gerbil,
working at the place, man.
[laughs]
I-I love -- I love being
a gerbil in that machine.
It's great.
[laughter]
O'LEARY: You know, Ryan,
I can time-travel,
and I've gone
to the future.
Here's the headline --
"Man dies of cardiac arrest
blending smoothies."
[laughter]
I'm out.
How long did it take you
to make that $70,000?
Well, since January.
And how much did you net?
We're netting 20%,
and we're anticipating
$150,000 worth of sales
from this cart next year,
$150,000 for our second cart,
and $150,000 for our third.
I think, you know,
it's very, very clever.
What do you mean,
"clever"?
I don't see it scaling.
I'm out.
Ryan, I think
it's a cute little business.
This looks like
it belongs on,
you know,
on an island or something.
It's really fun.
You know, piña coladas
being made out of it.
I just --
Yeah, that's true.
I could -- on a beach
or something, yeah?
You know, Gilligan actually used
one of these bikes.
[laughs]
Exactly.
But as for me...
I'm out.
Thank you.
I love the idea.
What I don't like
is the cost of the bikes.
Right.
Mark, he doesn't
make the bikes!
I know.
That's the catch.
If you were the bike guy instead
of the juice-and-smoothie guy,
I would be all over it.
I -- they're not doing
what I'm doing.
I-I think
you're innovative.
You took a concept
that I didn't even know existed,
the blender bike,
and turned it into a business.
If you were the bike guy
and you found an application
and smoothies
was the first application,
I'd be all over it,
but you're not,
and so for that reason, I'm out.
All right.
Well, thank you, Mark.
I appreciate that.
Good luck.
Thank you, guys.
Thanks, Ryan.
Take care.
It needs
to be on an island.
Making margaritas --
you got that one right.
Stupid.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is a former C.I.A. agent
who wants to expose
the tricks of the trade.
Hi, sharks.
My name is Jason Hanson.
My company
is Spy Escape & Evasion,
and I am seeking $100,000
in exchange
for 15% of my company.
The world of espionage
is a dangerous one.
To survive, you need to be able
to adapt to any situation.
You need to blend in
with your surroundings.
And only when necessary do you
reveal your true identity.
Actually, sharks, my name
is Hanson -- Jason Hanson.
Thank you for your help.
As a former C.I.A. officer,
I can also tell you
that you need to be able
to detect a threat.
You need to be able to adapt
to any situation, as mentioned.
You also need to be able
to escape capture.
Let's do a little training
exercise, and I'll show you.
Barbara,
do you mind assisting me?
I'm gonna have you come
and duct-tape my hands.
I love
this kind of stuff.
[laughter]
Don't tell Kevin!
What I'm gonna have you do
is just go around my wrists
three or four times --
whatever you prefer.
Happily.
Don't worry about the hair.
It'll grow back.
That's perfect.
[chuckles]
Thank you very much,
Barbara.
That's it?
I appreciate it.
That's -- well, there'll be
more later, I promise, okay?
I'm coming back.
You can hold on to that.
So, the fact is, sharks,
criminals love to use duct tape
to kidnap people,
but if the victims knew
how easy it is to escape,
many would still be alive.
Ooh.
JOHN: Oh, wow.
These techniques
are simple and effective.
But it's not just spies who can
benefit from this knowledge.
Everyday civilians
can use these secrets
to keep themselves
and their families safer.
What was that secret?
It's the angle.
So, if I got duct-taped
like this,
it wouldn't be as tight.
You got to have your elbows
together and tight.
That way, the friction of
going down at that exact angle,
and then it's gonna pop that.
Impressive.
Sharks, your mission,
should you choose to accept it,
is this.
Invest in me, and together,
we'll build Spy Escape & Evasion
into the largest
and most valuable
training experience
in the country.
Now, which one of you would like
some additional training?
Robert, you want some
additional training right now?
Yes.
Okay.
I love this stuff.
How about you come up here,
and let me grab a chair.
There you go. Perfect.
All right.
Okay.
So,
this is a zip tie --
but not the cheap, little ones
that can break easily.
Oh, you can't
get out of this.
I'm gonna show you.
So, what you do
is put your wrists together.
Okay.
So, Robert...
Wow.
You can just try
and go like that,
and they'll verify that...
it's the real deal.
If you were to look down
at my shoes,
you would see they appear
as regular dress shoes.
Also, the black laces,
they appear
as regular black laces.
What I've done is switched out
my laces with 550 cord,
also called parachute cord.
So, what I would do
is take off my shoelaces,
put them together,
but to save time,
this is what it would form.
So,
what you'd have to do --
and I'll do it for you,
Robert --
you go
right through there.
I'm gonna put this down
over this shoe.
Now, Robert would have
made this.
Now, Robert, you remember
how to ride a bicycle?
Yeah.
I'll get down on the ground
for you.
You're just gonna go like this
and bicycle,
and then
it's gonna pop that.
So just pretend
you're riding a bike.
Oh, my God!
There you go.
I'm amazed!
Hey!
Wow!
That easy.
That's unbelievable.
Thank you.
Wow.
Jason, were you really
a C.I.A. agent?
I am a former C.I.A. officer,
and if I had to tell you
any more,
I'd have to kill you, so...
Tell him more!
[laughs]
Yes, I'm really ex-C.I.A.
You're disposing
a lot of what I think
are proprietary pieces
of information.
I'm just wondering,
if I invested in you,
one day,
you don't show up for work.
[laughs]
Nothing I'm sharing
is confidential.
I've already had a talk
with the agency.
I'm allowed to do this.
I just can't share anything,
obviously --
so, you think the chances
of you getting whacked
and just being
turned into fish food are low.
I'm very good at what I do,
so I'd say it's low.
CUBAN: So, wait.
You haven't told us
what the business is,
what you're trying to do,
so...
Spy escape & evasion
is a two-day course.
The first day, you learn
Spy Escape & Evasion skills
such as how to pick locks,
how to escape rope,
how to escape duct tape,
how to detect and evade
surveillance.
Day 2 is
a field-training exercise,
so you take all the operational
skills from day 1,
you go on a series of missions,
and I have trackers
and surveillance guys
hunting you down to see if
you can complete your missions.
Now, it's a very fun,
exciting course,
but it's also
a practical self-defense course
to keep you safe.
Do you have this in place
right now?
Correct. Yes.
And what are your sales?
$306,000 gross,
$128,000 net.
Was that in one year,
or was that over
a period of time?
That's in one year.
That is year-to-date.
Who is this course
designed for?
Great question.
So, it started out
for high-net-worth individuals,
so I was just doing it
for C.E.O.s, executives.
But then I had -- just everyday
people started taking my course.
How much is the course?
This course is $600.
For two days?
Correct.
And where are you at?
Where are you based?
Cedar City, Utah.
[laughing]
Cedar City, Utah?
Well, actually,
I just moved there last year --
I'm from
the Washington, D.C., area --
and so I was
teaching it there, doing well,
moved out there,
and that's actually
what I want to talk to you about
for the money for.
Okay.
My wife and I have 320 acres
that we're gonna close in
two weeks in Cedar City, Utah,
and I want to build
Spy Escape & Evasion ranch.
I want to make it a premier
self-defense training facility.
[laughing]
Spy escape & evasion ranch!
So, we're gonna teach
the spy courses.
I want to do evasive driving,
which you would love.
And then I want to have
a whole spy obstacle course,
the toughest obstacle
course on the planet.
But that's gonna
require more capital to
build that out, right?
You're gonna need m--
Well, that's what I want
the $100,000 for.
How are you making money
right now off the course?
'cause you don't have
the land developed yet,
so how are you making money
right now?
Right now,
I fly around the country,
so I do a course in Las Vegas,
in Washington, D.C.,
in San Di--
And how do acquire
those customers?
Magazine ads
and then internet.
But what if we want to get
to $20 million in sales, right?
Just Jason's
not gonna be enough.
Who else is out there
that can be
an authoritative teacher
so we could grow this?
Obviously,
I'm gonna find people
with ex-agency background
or ex-military background.
I mean, I've had a ton of these
guys already take my course.
CORCORAN: It really is a mistake
on your part
assuming people
will come out to Utah
to come
and be at your camp,
so I'm out.
All right, well,
I'm sorry to hear that, Barbara.
Jason, what I see
is two different directions.
The Model That seems to work
is when you go to a city,
show up for two days,
train people.
They don't want to fly to Utah,
because it's too expensive.
It quadruples the cost
and takes a lot of time.
I do not want to invest
in the Ponderosa.
[laughter]
But what you guys haven't
let me say is I'm flexible.
I obviously lack the knowledge.
If you guys, who are much
smarter businesspeople than me,
say, "You know what?
This is the model.
It's not the land."
Obviously, I'd be an idiot
not to listen to that,
because you have
the business experience
and the knowledge
that I lack.
It's half-baked.
I'm out.
All right.
Thank you, Kevin.
Jason,
I love this stuff.
I actually think there's
a pretty big market for it.
But I hate the business idea
you came out here with today.
I mean...
Forget about the land, then.
[laughter]
I'm flexible.
I lack the knowledge.
You know, and --
What land?
There goes the Ponderosa.
I'm trying
to be nice to you,
'cause you could be
packing heat, so I don't know.
I am interested in the idea
of selling the seminar,
but you should be filling
entire seminar rooms,
like big hotel rooms.
and I lack the marketing
knowledge to do that.
Well, the other thing
you're lacking
is you don't have
any upsell.
Mm-hmm.
You should have
a subscription -- e-mail
or "Here's the latest threats
in the world" --
Stuff like that.
Right.
But I think you're the guy.
I think you could make it.
I think
you could build that
into a multi-million-dollar
business.
I'll make you
an offer.
Okay.
I'll give you $100,000
for 50%.
First thing we got to do
is you got to create
some material
that you can sell
at these places,
and then
we start testing cities
to see
what the paying point is
and how we can use that money
to build larger seminars.
$100,000 for 50%.
Look, that's the offer
I'm gonna make you,
and I'm only making you
that offer because
it's a completely different plan
than you came out with.
I understand.
Greedy savage, table of one.
Your table's ready.
It's the right business.
If you want to invest
in land in Utah, Daymond...
Are you gonna make him
an offer
or just insult
the only one he's got?
NARRATOR:
Two sharks are out.
Robert has made Jason an offer
of $100,000
for a 50% stake
in his company.
Look, that's the offer
I'm gonna make you,
and I'm only making
that offer because
it's a completely different plan
than you came out with.
I understand.
Greedy savage, table of one.
Your table's ready.
It's the right business.
If you want to invest
in land in Utah, Daymond...
Are you gonna make him
an offer
or just insult
the only one he's got?
[laughing] I'm so amazed
at the offer he just got.
Daymond? Mark?
Look, I like the kind of
training aspect of it.
That's interesting.
But I don't see that
as the grand slam.
I think the hottest trend
right now in entertainment
is experiences, right?
I could absolutely,
positively see putting together
a fun, you know,
one-day or overnight spy school.
Mm-hmm.
And you're charging 50 bucks
or 60 bucks or 70 bucks,
and you might get
300, 400 people coming through
and doing
all these different things.
O'LEARY:
By the time this is over,
you're gonna have to
send him an invoice
for rewriting
his business plan.
[laughs]
That's okay,
'cause, see,
That's the difference
between us, Kevin.
You just look
and see A, B, and C.
It's a weakness
in the presentation.
I look at A, B, and C
and see X, Y, Z.
That's the difference
between us.
It's a weakness
in the presentation.
No, it's not.
It's just an opportunity.
Like he said,
he's an entrepreneur.
I think
Jason's gonna kidnap
both of you in a moment
if you don't hurry up.
What are you doing?
What are you doing, Mark?
Well, talk to Daymond,
'cause I'm uncertain.
I'm on --
I'm on the fence.
Ay. All that
for being on the fence?
Well, ask questions, you know?
You got to learn.
All right. Daymond, sir.
You cannot build
this property.
You have to be able
to move around with it.
And that's fine.
I know your model.
Your model needs, really,
to be for moms and families
and homes
in high-populated areas
where they feel
that they could potentially face
home invasion and other things
of that nature.
Here's my offer --
$150,000 for 45% --
but you got to take the offer
right now.
Not gonna give me
a 24-second shot clock?
No. That's it.
All right. Let's do it. Done.
Good.
Good move.
He's your best partner.
Thank you.
Thank you, sir.
All right.
I appreciate it.
Yeah. You got it.
Thank you.
I like this guy.
Congrats, Jason.
Thank you.
Today, I walked into the tank
with a mission,
and I think it was accomplished.
If we can teach thousands
upon thousands of people
and one person's life
gets saved by this,
then it's definitely worth it.
NARRATOR:
Last season, we watched
Doug Marshall strike a deal
with Mark and Lori
for his unique alternative
to face paint, gameface.
Let's do it.
Put your gameface on!
Put your gameface on, baby!
Whoo-hoo!
NARRATOR:
Let's see how he's doing now.
MARSHALL: Making a deal
with Mark and Lori
was the best thing I could have
done for my company.
Get your gameface on, guys!
Let's go!
My dream has always been
to be able to feature gamefaces
at professional sport
league games around the country.
Mark made that dream come true
by allowing us to give out
thousands of gamefaces
to his most loyal mav fans.
Hey, Mark.
What's up, dawg?
[chuckles]
Good to see you.
CUBAN: When we first did
the deal on "Shark Tank,"
I knew it'd be a winner,
but, you know,
it's good to get validation.
When you bring it out
to the mavs games
and the kids go nuts over it,
we're showing them
on the jumbotron
and everybody's going crazy
seeing them, this is exciting.
I know Lori and I
are really fired up.
Showing your fan pride
has just changed 180 degrees
with gameface.
MARSHALL:
We had been working on this
for five, six years
and slowly being accepted.
Since "Shark Tank,"
all of a sudden, bam --
everybody wants it.
In our first year of business,
we did $6,700 in sales.
In the 10-month period
since airing,
we've done $200,000 in sales.
In order to keep up with demand,
we had to change
our manufacturing process.
With the finalization
of the product,
we're able to project sales
of $2- to $20 million
in the next 12 months.
The possibilities for gameface
are endless.
We're gonna have them
in all the colors
of all the different teams.
Our next step
is to launch licensed product
from the NFL, NBA,
NHL, and NCAA.
We're even working with
international soccer sponsors
for the 2014 world cup.
Those orders
could be in the millions.
ALL: Defense!
MARSHALL: So many people
want a small business
or just have an idea.
I had an idea,
created a business,
went in front of the sharks,
and it's changed our life
beyond our wildest dreams.
[crowd cheers]
NARRATOR: Next up is
a former wrestling superstar
with a product
that changed his life.
Hello, sharks.
I'm former WWE world champion
diamond Dallas Page.
And I'm Dallas' partner,
Steve yu.
Our company's ddp yoga,
and today, we're seeking
$200,000 for 5% of the company.
Ddp yoga was created
out of necessity.
You see, I didn't even become
a professional wrestler
until I was 35 years old.
My career did not take off
until I was 40.
By the time I was 42,
I was at the top
of the wrestling business,
and bang!
I blew my back out
so badly
that three different
back specialists said
my wrestling career
was over.
So,
when it was suggested
that I might try yoga
to heal my body,
I got to be honest --
I was like, "Yoga?
I'm a guy who wouldn't
be caught dead doing yoga!"
But I was desperate
to save my career,
so I gave it a shot,
and in less than three months,
I was back in the ring.
I proved the doctors wrong,
and at 43 years young,
I was the heavyweight
champ of the world --
not once, not twice,
but three times.
You see, sharks, ddp yoga --
it ain't your mama's yoga.
I combine the very best
of my old-school training
with sports-rehabilitation
techniques, yoga positions,
and dynamic resistance
to create the most
complete workout on the planet.
It will dramatically increase
your flexibility
and strengthen your core
like never before --
all with
minimal joint impact.
No other workout
can make that statement.
Now, Dallas has spent years
developing this program,
and we officially launched
ddp yoga two years ago,
and we couldn't be more inspired
by people doing the workouts.
Now, before you start
to grill us,
let me show you
what ddp yoga did for me.
When I blew my back out,
this is
where my flexibility was.
Today, this is where
my flexibility is.
[exhales deeply]
Wow.
PAGE: And being able
to stand here and talk to you,
at 6'4", 226 pounds,
and 57 years young,
this is core strength
and balance
at a whole different level.
This is ddp yoga.
Now, to show you that
just about anyone can do this,
let me tell you about a guy
named Arthur boorman --
disabled veteran
that was 5'6", 297 pounds
when I first got with him
and couldn't walk
without the aid of knee braces,
back brace, or wraparound canes.
Let me introduce you to him.
Arthur, come on down here.
He not only lost 140 pounds
in 10 months,
he lost the knee braces,
the back brace,
and the wraparound canes --
can not only walk, but run.
CORCORAN: Whoa, no way.
This is not the same guy.
This is -.
This is the same guy.
Wow.
CUBAN:
Good for you, buddy.
Former staff sergeant
Arthur boorman.
Wow.
What a beast.
Over 10 million views
on his video.
Really?
Really.
JOHN: Wow. Congrats.
Arthur, you swear to God
that's you in the video?
That is me in the video.
CUBAN: Yeah, it looks like him.
Yeah.
I mean, face-wise.
Amazing.
Wow.
Arthur,
why don't you show them
some of the things
that you can do now?
He couldn't stand on two legs,
never mind one leg.
Good for you, Arthur.
And his flexibility --
cold.
CUBAN: Oh, damn.
JOHN: Whoa.
Oh, wow.
Wow.
PAGE: 53 years young.
And how did you find
Dallas?
Well, y-you kind of have to
understand how desperate I was.
I was really bad-off.
I could not -- I couldn't
do anything on my own.
My wife had to dress me
in the morning.
I could not
live like that anymore,
and I tried different things,
and nothing worked.
So, I was on the internet,
typing in different things,
and one time, I just typed in
"Yoga, broken back" --
up popped
Dallas Page.
CORCORAN: Wow.
Hm.
Okay, so, let's get into
the business, Dallas, guys.
Sure.
Yeah, the first year,
we -- we pretty much beat
our expectations.
We were hoping to do maybe
a quarter of a million dollars,
and we actually sold
$2.6 million.
Oh, wow.
JOHN: In the first year?
Today,
we just broke $3 million.
Dang.
YU:
We broke $3 million.
PAGE:
And that's with DVDs.
Well, what was your profit
on the $3 million yielded?
We netted $890,000.
Before you paid yourselves
anything?
Oh, we paid ourselves.
So, that's after
you paid yourselves.
Oh, yeah.
So, if I gave you
$200,000,
how exactly
would you spend that money?
We would put that
towards building
the first mobile application
for ddp yoga.
So, it's still being
sold in a DVD and
a book format, right?
Right.
That's right.
So, where do you come from,
Steve?
How -- how did you end up,
you know, working with Dallas?
I started trying to do
filmmaking to create stories
that would inspire people
to change their lives,
and then, you know,
Dallas and I spoke about it,
and I said,
"Well, let me --
"You know, I've got
a lot of documentary footage.
Let me try
to retell Arthur's story."
I'll tell you
what's really fascinating me
and concerning me.
We see
a lot of exercise programs
coming into the Shark Tank.
All the models we've seen,
including the ones
that have been successful,
have used an ingredient
that's very expensive --
infomercials.
They bought remnant time
on cable.
That's the barrier to entry
in this space.
Yes.
And so what I'm concerned about
in looking at your deal
is you don't have
any of that in place.
Yes, we do.
We start airing our Doc--
not an infomercial,
it's a docu-mercial --
we're reinventing
the infomercial.
Are you buying
the airtime?
Yes.
We've already bought it.
We're testing now.
We're testing right now.
CORCORAN: Wait. How much money
did you spend on it?
Well, they've got $890,000
in profits.
That's what you do
with profits, right?
Yeah, so, we -- yeah,
we didn't have
that flexibility before.
Reinvest.
JOHN: So,
here's what I think, Dallas.
I think that you're asking
for $200,000, 5%.
You're valuing the company
at $4 million.
Really, that's not bad,
to be very honest.
Um, but I've invested
in some fitness brands before --
Billy Blanks Jr.,
cowboy Ryan --
and I'm finding out
about all the challenges.
It is a massive, massive drain
on my time and energy,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Thank you very much.
You guys know
as well as I do --
and I think
that's why you're here --
that there will be
a transition.
It's gonna get more difficult
to sell DVDs.
The difficult factor
for me
is that
when you transition to online,
the pricing, the profitability,
the risk/reward
is 180 degrees different,
right?
So coming in,
we're creating a new company.
It's just too great
a risk profile for me.
Sure.
And so while I say,
"Good job, good effort,"
I have to say,
for that reason, I'm out.
Thanks. Appreciate that.
Thank you,
and congrats, guys.
I don't like investing
in businesses that are
based on trends.
All the up and down,
it just doesn't work for me.
I fear that your big hit
already happened
on the backs
of this great story.
I don't have the faith
to go up and down
on the roller-coaster ride
with you.
I'm out.
The challenge I have is,
as Mark said,
is you want to create
a brand-new business.
You're gonna burn
all your profit
going into
the infomercial route.
The thing about that,
Robert,
is we're not going
into this infomercial world
and just
dumping our money in.
We're -- we're being
very cautious.
Maybe. I just -- I'm --
I'm not believing in that route.
And for the 5% for $200,000
when you're making $900,000,
you know,
I just don't see it.
I'm out.
Well, Mr. Wonderful?
O'LEARY: Yeah. Here's --
here's where I'm at.
[chuckles]
It's rare that I --
I've got a, you know,
an angel and a devil
on my shoulders
saying, "Do this deal.
Just ask for more."
You're offering me $200,000
for 5%.
$200,000 for 50%
would be more along...
[laughs]
YU: Yeah. [laughs]
I'm a good salesman, too,
and the reason you'd do this
is I have to write another check
and another check
and another check after
you figure out the metrics.
Yeah, so then he'll own 70%,
and then 80%, then 120%.
That's why
they call me Mr. Wonderful.
You made $900,000
this year.
You're offering that?
God. What an insult.
Unfortunately, the angst
I have about the future
can't be ignored,
so, for that reason, I'm out.
PAGE: I really appreciate
your time,
and you're gonna watch ddp yoga
become a household name.
YU: Absolutely.
You're gonna be going,
"Oh, God!
Why wasn't I
a part of that?"
Thank you so much, guys.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
See ya. Bang!
Appreciate it.
[laughter]
CUBAN: Good job.
Good effort, guys.
I was almost gonna
have to hold Dallas back
when he offered,
you know,
he wanted
50% of our company.
oh, boy.
I was eyeing him up
right there, man.
Bang!
[laughing]
Mr. Wonderful.
Not so wonderful
no more, bro.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
with an easy, gourmet way
to make
a favorite breakfast treat.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Erica Barrett.
I'm from Atlanta, Georgia,
and I'm the founder and C.E.O.
Of Southern culture
artisan foods,
a breakfast lifestyle brand.
I'm seeking $100,000
in exchange
for a 25% equity stake
in my company.
One morning, I was simply
making breakfast for my husband
and had to run to the store
to grab ingredients
to make our all-time favorite,
strawberry pancakes.
I wanted to use organic flour,
pure cane sugar,
fresh strawberries,
and, sharks, what's pancakes
without great vanilla?
I got to the register,
and my bill was close to $35.
Stop the madness!
I hadn't even
bought the bacon yet.
And I thought to myself,
"Why isn't there a quality
flavored pancake-and-waffle mix
currently on the shelf?"
So, with no formal
culinary experience,
I created
our flagship product --
shortstacks
pancake & waffle mix.
We feature unique flavors,
such as banana pudding,
oatmeal-raisin cookie,
and even bourbon salted pecan.
We use organic,
all-natural ingredients,
and because our mixes contain
no powdered dairy,
I've literally masterminded
a product
that's great for all diets.
But enough about my breakfasts.
I have some samples
for you to try.
We're about to eat.
Yes, breakfast.
Absolutely. Feed us!
All right.
Oh, wow.
Here you go, Robert.
Just looking at it...
Barbara.
Thank you.
Are these
all the same flavors?
They have
no carbs at all.
Yes, it's our banana pudding,
our best seller.
CORCORAN: Thank you so much.
HERJAVEC: This is banana?
Banana-pudding pancake.
It smells fantastic.
Mr. Wonderful. Here you go.
Banana-pudding pancake.
JOHN: Thank you.
Here you go, Mark.
Yes, Ma'am.
Mmm.
Barbara, a moment on the lips,
a lifetime on your hips.
[chuckles]
It's worth it.
Mmm!
Sharks, we've had
quite a bit of success.
Now I'm ready to take this brand
to the next level.
There's only one question
I have for you.
This is so good.
Who's ready to take a bite
out of the most important meal
of the day?
Mmm.
Erica,
tell us about your sales.
Well,
within our first 12 months,
we did $100,000 in sales.
Mmm.
We had gross profits
of $62,000.
Where'd you sell
that $100,000?
Well, Nordstrom picked us up
immediately
after we went
to our first trade show.
T.J. Maxx and Marshalls
also picked up our product.
You've gotten into
some high-end retailers.
Absolutely.
And have they reordered
from you?
Nordstrom, we're working
on an order with them
for the holiday season.
They usually do food
around the holidays, like --
typically, people pick them up
as a gift item.
Uh, we do have Whole Foods.
I do Williams-Sonoma
artisans market once a month.
Is this very expensive versus
just traditional pancake mix?
What does it cost?
Well, it costs me anywhere
between 99 cents and $1.50
to make the product.
It sells for about $7.99.
Great margins.
How many waffles
does that make?
12 pancakes
or 4 large waffles.
That's a very, very high price
for that small quantity.
Can I see the packaging,
Erica?
Yes. Absolutely.
So, Erica,
if I'm walking into Whole Foods
and I see
four products there...
Mm-hmm.
...What's the difference
between yours
and the other three?
Why would I pick yours up?
Well, the first thing
about our product
is that we use
premium ingredients.
Well, you've got
the Southern thing going, right?
Absolutely.
So that's the whole thing.
You've kind of created
a little vertical niche, right?
A niche, absolutely.
Southern gourmet.
Or just a great,
quality pancake
that's not filled
with chemicals.
We use real blueberries.
So, my concern
about growing this business is,
how do I scale it?
I don't think
you have a permanent listing
in any of the stores
you talked to me about.
Uh, Whole Foods -- we've been
in Whole Foods for a year.
Okay, how many times
have they reordered?
It's a local -- it's a local
Whole Foods, correct?
Regional, yeah.
We're in 12 stores.
And how many times
have they reordered?
They reorder every week.
And why can't you get
a national rollout on that?
Well, Whole Foods told us
that they want us to build
a great track record.
We couldn't get in contact
with the regional buyers,
so we hustled our way
into every single store.
We called up every single
team leader and said,
"I guarantee,
if you purchase this product,
you're gonna get reorders."
There hasn't been anything
in my life --
my mom had me at 16 years old,
I'm a first-generation
college student --
that I've set out to achieve
that I have not done.
I mean, I haven't --
I think I take naps.
I won't say that I go to sleep.
But I'm obsessed
with my business,
because this is
what I'm here to do.
That's awesome.
Good for you.
If this category
takes off,
why wouldn't you think
the big brands,
everybody out there,
would say...
so good.
..."I'll just create
my own brand"?
I think you already have
competitors in this category,
don't you?
Well --
Yeah, there's competitors.
Um, there's --
Well, Kevin --
Kevin's trying to say
the big boys
are gonna wipe you out,
but the big boys already
know about this category.
Yeah.
That's what I'm saying.
HERJAVEC: Yeah, right?
Absolutely.
But Kevin
always says that.
And I want to know
the answer.
I think what makes me different
is that,
you know, traditional
manufacturers have made
their breakfast products
the same way for 80 to 85 years,
but people change.
People have
dietary restrictions.
People are vegan.
People are lactose-intolerant.
But I want to hear more
about the ones
who are currently
in your space,
the ones
who are making other products.
Yeah, the premium ones
you compete with --
do they not make the product
the same way?
They use powdered dairy.
So, your claim is
you're the purest of the pure.
Absolutely.
So, you've done a remarkable job
in 16 months.
You're making money.
Your packaging is amazing.
Why are you here?
What do you need the money for?
I need to fill orders.
Okay.
QVC just sent me an e-mail
this morning.
They want to pick me up
for their fourth-quarter lineup.
They believe that we can sell
50,000 to 75,000.
Let me just
slow you down, there.
I've had
so many food products on QVC.
Mm-hmm.
They have sold
wildly successfully.
Uh-huh.
And you know what
the problem with them are?
The margins are so skinny
that you basically break even.
Mm-hmm.
The way to make money
in the food space,
which I learned the hard way
over and over and over again,
is to get into
the big-box stores.
That's where
the margins are fat.
And you know
what I've learned?
I've learned that
boutique businesses like this...
Uh-huh.
...aren't sold there.
We were actually approached
by target,
that wants to start us off
at 50 to 100 test stores.
You're under a lucky star.
Where do you manufacture this?
We manufacture the product
ourself.
What do you mean, "yourself"?
Wait a minute --
you don't have a commer--
in your own kitchen?
You box it, you make it?
You don't have
a commercial kitchen?
We have our own facilities --
3,000 square feet.
Oh.
Why wouldn't you go
to a commercial kitchen?
Because they could
reduce your costs dramatically.
I think what we're doing
that's so unique, Mr. wonderful,
they can't produce this.
They want to put --
They want to put me in a box.
No, no, no, wait, wait, wait.
Just hear me out on this.
'cause all of us have food deals
in our portfolios now.
Okay.
I have learned that
a commercial co-packer kitchen
is the only way to go.
Your costs are reduced
by 30%.
Okay.
Erica,
I'll start to simplify things.
You're amazing,
but I'm not really
into the gourmet-food business.
If it's more than $3
or more than a hot dog
at 7-Eleven,
that's too much for me,
and, you know,
it's not my kind of thing,
so for that reason,
I'm out.
Thank you.
But awesome.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
Erica,
I think that you made
a really fatal and critical
flaw here today.
Uh, you didn't give me
enough food.
[laughter]
Unbelievable.
Thank you.
But here's the one thing
I've learned
from my food investments.
Yes.
The food business
is a really tough business.
I see this
as a high-end niche product,
but not a big business.
For that reason, I'm out.
Thank you.
Look,
I'm gonna make you an offer,
but it's gonna have a bunch
of contingencies in it.
Okay.
Which you're gonna want
to say no to right away.
I haven't heard anyb--
Silence.
Silence, Barbara, because
you're not making any offer.
You might as well listen
to where the money is
for the moment, all right?
You can't do what you want to do
in 3,000 square feet,
so contingency number 1,
before I give you $100,000,
is that you're gonna
have to work with a co-packer.
You're gonna have to.
Okay.
Secondly, I'm not interested
in any equity.
I want a dollar a unit.
Oh! [groans]
Silence.
I want a dollar a unit
until I recoup my $100,000,
and then
I'll go down to 50 cents --
the exact same offer
I gave Dani and Tracey
for Wicked Cupcakes.
They love me now --
Love me, all right?
Okay.
That's why
I'm called Mr. Wonderful.
Erica,
what's your cost per unit?
About anywhere
from 92 cents to $1.50.
So you're gonna pay Kevin
more than it costs you --
You know what?
No, you don't get it.
Because when you go
to the co-packer,
one third of that dollar's
gonna be recouped.
That doesn't make
any sense.
She's paying you --
She's paying you more.
I've made an offer.
If you want to make an offer,
Robert, go ahead and make one.
She's paying you more than
it costs to make the product.
You are so lucky you've met me.
You have no idea.
So you can learn
what not to do.
Let's hear your offer.
You -- oh, you're out.
I forgot.
Now, how about you,
Daymond?
NARRATOR: Two sharks are out,
Erica has an offer from Kevin,
and Daymond is on the fence.
How about you,
Daymond?
I'll make you an offer.
CUBAN: Thank God.
And I don't even know
if I really want to
make you an offer.
I just don't want to see you
in bed with this character.
But I'll make you
a $100,000 offer for 40%.
You thief!
You really do
come in on a broom.
No, not at all.
And the reason for that
is I don't think you really know
what's ahead of you.
You haven't dealt with
the stores that don't pay you.
You haven't dealt with QVC,
where if a customer complains,
wham --
They slam it back to you
and they charge you
for the shipping.
Okay.
You haven't really gone
to the sophomore year,
where you are about to have to
overcome tremendous hurdles
that almost put every one of my
entrepreneurs out of business.
Okay.
It's problem after problem
after problem.
You know
one of the biggest problems?
You got to listen to this
every day.
Which is a whole lot better
than that.
[laughs]
O'LEARY: So much jealousy here,
you know?
Erica, so...
I, uh,
I-I'm one of the only sharks
without food
in my portfolio,
so one of my main agendas
this year
is to put some food
in my portfolio.
Looks like
you haven't missed many meals.
[chuckles] No. In my stomach,
they're all there.
I'm a hard worker.
I'm a hard worker, Daymond.
You know,
but what I see here
is that you do have
a horrible offer with Kevin.
I believe you have a great
potential partner with Barbara,
so I'm gonna step out.
What do you think, Erica?
What do you think?
Barbara,
I would like to counter.
Fair.
Is it possible
we could do 30%
in exchange for the $100,000?
I'm a hard worker.
No, I would have to stay firm
with the 40%.
Oh, come on, Barbara.
Again, because --
Wow.
Because I know how much work
is involved in this
from this point forward.
35%.
[clicks tongue]
Afraid not.
But I want you
to be happy with the deal.
Barbara!
Have a heart, Barbara.
Come on.
You can make 35%.
I'm a hard worker.
Now you know
what evil looks like on Earth.
No way we can do 35% and just
kind of meet in the middle?
You savage.
I mean, a little bit more
than the middle?
I'll make you
a lot of money, Barbara.
I'm a hard worker.
I have the right to be here.
I've worked so hard.
CUBAN, JOHN, AND HERJAVEC:
Barbara! Barbara!
Barbara! Barbara! Barbara!
BARRETT: Come on, Barbara.
Come on, Barbara!
O'LEARY: Erica.
Abandon this madness.
Do the Mr. Wonderful deal.
What's 5%?
Come on, Barbara.
Come on, Barbara!
Well...38%.
[laughs]
You got a deal.
[all cheer]
All right!
And you don't have a deal,
Mr. Wonderful!
Yeah!
I'm okay with that.
CUBAN: Way to go, Erica!
Whoo, baby!
And I love pancakes.
Awesome.
Thank you so much!
Congratulations, Erica.
Thank you.
Excellent job.
CORCORAN: Looking forwar.
To working with you, baby.
Thank you.
Yes! [laughs]
I can't believe it.
Flattened Mr. Wonderful
like a pancake.
Take that, Mr. Meanie pants.
[chuckles]
O'LEARY: I'm okay with it.
You'll never get your money
out of that --
ever. ever.
That woman hated you
on sight.
She loved me.
I didn't want to give up
that much equity,
but I trust Barbara,
I know that she cares
about my well-being,
and I know
that I'm gonna be a millionaire.